on les côtoie tous les jours il nous
émerveille par leurs chants leur plumage
leurs noms sont souvent intrigant
difficile à retenir aussi parfois mais
comment nos moutons ou juste les oiseaux
[Musique]
glee des prêts mouettes de bonaparte
bruyant chanteur cardinal rouge ou
encore l'oie des neiges qu'il nous faut
autant de noms qui lie à d'oiseaux
environ 400 espèces d'oiseaux nichent au
canada auquel il faut ajouter près de
200 espèces accidentelle c'est à dire
celles qui ne sont que de passage
oui mercier et professeur associé à la
faculté des lettres et sciences humaines
de l'université de sherbrooke il rédige
actuellement un dictionnaire historique
des noms d'oiseaux le quand on regarde
des listes de noms d'oiseaux se rend
compte qu'on exploite et différents
traits pour les nommés par exemple ce
qui est le plus courant c'est la couleur
la couleur globale ou un aspect coloré
de l'oiseau ou un autre aspect de sa
morphologie on a utilisé son habitat
vont par exemple j'ai bleus c'est la
couleur mésanges à tête moi c'est un
aspect le geai des chênes c'est un
milieu forestier les chenilles rc sa
nourriture et à le cri aussi ce qui a
servi faire des onomatopées comme
tricherie
enfin il ya des noms de
d'ornithologues célèbre conte exploiter
pour s'y retrouver les scientifiques
classe c la taxonomie la science de la
classification des êtres vivants pour
être classé oiseaux il faut voler avoir
des plumes et pondre des oeufs une
espèce est toujours définie par deux
noms
cette pratique de dénommer les oiseaux à
partir de deux éléments l'élément
générique qui cible un groupe et
éléments plus spécifique qui vient d'y
limiter une espèce particulièrement
s'était mis en place ou au milieu du
xviiie siècle par le naturaliste suédois
carl von linné quand on veut parler de
l'histoire des noms et fausses y est de
clarifier différentes catégories de nom
par exemple le nom oies blanches qui est
toujours usuels au québec à côté de ça
il ya le nom technique oies des neiges
qui lui est celui qui sert de référence
dans la communauté des ornithologues
mais la référence ultime c'est le nom
scientifique latin qui est établie par
les grands organismes internationaux
mais en amérique du nord les noms
d'oiseaux en anglais sont déterminées
par la société américaine d'ornithologie
ou un os tandis que les noms en français
ont été uniformisées pour la dernière
fois en 1993 par la commission
internationale des non-français des
oiseaux suit un premier rapprochement
des nomenclatures dans les années 80
c'est là que nous fauvettes sont devenus
des péruvienne
et que nous passons sont devenus des
bruits
les noms d'oiseaux sont donc sujets à
changement ces dernières décennies c'est
principalement à cause de l'analyse de
l'adn que certains oiseaux change de
famille comme la paruline polyglotte qui
est devenu lic terry polyglotte mais
depuis quelques années un autre
mouvement a vu le jour pour changer les
noms d'oiseaux actuellement aux
etats-unis on voit poindre un mouvement
qui
demande à ce qu'on
on abandonne tous les noms tous les noms
de personnes en fait de deux
d'ornithologues qui figurent dans les
dénominations d'oiseaux et les remplacer
simplement par des traits plus
caractéristiques
c'est le cas du plectre fans de mac en
qu'on appelle désormais claque trop fan
à votre grille
[Musique]
mais qu'elle était un général de l'armée
confédérée il est un exemple typique du
type de personnes honorées par des noms
d'oiseaux jordan twitter et ornithologue
et co-fondatrice du mouvement burns
forbach
quand vous parlez de noise ou comme les
paires vie de couple ou le casse-noix
d'amérique qu'est ce que c'est non
indiquent à quelqu'un qui ne connaît pas
ces oiseaux en réévaluant les noms de m
forbes souhaitent célébrer l'oiseau en
tant que tel certaines des personnes
honorées par lé nom éponyme honteux pas
ces problématiques et on fait des choses
horribles qui ne correspondent pas à la
morale et aux valeurs d'aujourd'hui
c'est environ 10 % des espèces d'oiseaux
dans le monde qui sont dotés d'un
patronyme on en retrouve 150 en amérique
du nord en anglais et 250 en français le
dossier est désormais entre les mains de
la société américaine dans mythologies
mais pensez aussi que dans le domaine de
la botanique il ya énormément de noms de
botanistes aussi qui ont été mentionnés
alors quelle sera la suite de ce
mouvement on peut pas le dire ni pour
l'instant e
[Musique]